[Musique]
la france est en train de se déliter
il est inutile de se cacher la réalité
des choses notre pays par pans entiers
est en train de perdre son unité qui
attendaient la république et la
démocratie chez nous il ya un vrai enjeu
pour demain des républicains nous sommes
aujourd'hui soucieux et désirait trouver
les solutions à la montée des
communautarismes
or on voit bien que le pouvoir en place
cache cette réalité reporte les discours
assez de noyés sous des séparatismes il
y a un problème de séparatistes
islamistes et nous devons être capacité
de le regarder en face part dans des
théories racistes et certains voudraient
nourrir mais par amour dans la
république
par amour de la france aux républicains
c'est ce que nous souhaitons faire
rejoignez nous parce que ce combat c'est
le combat toile
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
où
[Musique]